I can start alright so as I said this
morning I'm not an information theorist
data scientist a learning person or
anything like that so no data is going
to be harmed in this talk but so I'm a
proper list and you know so my interest
is in you know and in sort of two things
the minor one is to generate tools that
many people can use probabilistic tools
but for me more interesting is to try to
develop sort of some sort of fundamental
understanding of the mechanisms that
make certain phenomena appear on
different problems right and and so I
have 25 minutes so there is a sort of
limited amount of time that I can go but
I will try to convince you that there
something to be understood something can
be understood and there's a lot that's
not understood so let's talk about
random matrices so this is joint work
with a firm so bandera who also showed
up in a manuals talk and who is a very
talented graduate student at Princeton
so um let's talk about random matrices
right so there's a in machine learning
in statistics and information theory
Sergio has all book about it right the
random matrices show up more and more
and they show up next the lot in in high
dimensional problems now if you go to
the mathematical literature you'll find
a huge literature on random matrices
almost all of it is on very very
symmetric matrices things like like
matrices with iid entries and for
mathematicians this is a very beautiful
theory it has so much symmetry that
there's a lot of integrable structure
you can write down a lot of limiting
exact limiting distributions you know
you can understand the full statistics
etc on the other hand if this matrix has
some structure right so if it doesn't if
it's not the really symmetric matrix but
it has some actual non-trivial structure
almost this entire theory breaks down
and there's not that much literature out
there about structured random matrices
of course in applications at least the
ones I'm not really equipped to talk
about I'll try to say something at the
very end but this is outside sort of my
in my scope but but in applications
often its structured matrices that show
up but not these very very symmetric
matrices right and so one needs some
sort of mathematical tools to understand
matrices that are structured and the
reason that really isn't all that much
right and then one of the few things
that's out there is this business of
matrix concentration which many of you
might have heard of
so this is very popular right now it's
used all over the place in in in in many
different results and it is almost
always not correct or correct it's
correct but it's always almost always
suboptimal all right and I'm going to
try to convince you that that one can in
principle do better at least in one
special case and and and that there's
something to be understood so let's take
I'm going to take the simplest possible
structured model of a mana matrix that
that that exhibit some sort of
non-trivial structure so let's do a very
simple problem so here's a simple
question so let's take X to be an N by n
symmetric matrix
so many of these things that I'm going
to write down can be relaxed but let's
just take a very simple model just to
have something to talk about
so let's take those entries that are not
fixed let's say the upper day are the
entries above the diagonal to be
independent and be Gaussian with mean
zero and some given variances an
independent so what's important here
symmetric is not important it can be
even a rectangular matrix Gaussian is
not important but independent is
important so I'm going to speak about
matrices weird which have independent
entries but they have non-trivial
structure in the sense that they can
have the different entries can have
different variances and the variances
are given right so this is a matrix
structure so there's no symmetry here
really and we're going to try to
understand something about this matrix
in terms of the structure of the of the
variances and the simple question is
what can we say what can be said about
the spectral norm of this matrix let's
say the expected expected spectral
normal of the matrix we want to
understand what aspect of the structure
of the variances of the entries controls
the spectral norm of the matrix so okay
let's so let's talk about what's known
so the classical case is weak
this is the so-called Wigner case so the
Wigner case is just when the entries of
this matrix are IID okay so let's say
all of the BI J's all of the variances
are equal to one this is the case where
you have a matrix let's say symmetric
matrix whose three entries are iid
Gaussian random variables normals ero 1
and in this case the structure of this
matrix is extremely well understood
right there beautiful results many of
you have probably seen it right so if we
draw a histogram of all the eigenvalues
of this matrix it looks like a
semicircle very accurately if you have
never seen this before go in MATLAB draw
such a matrix plot its histogram you
will see the beautiful semicircle
showing up ok so this is a histogram of
the eigenvalues is a semicircle and its
edge here is exactly a 2 square root N
and here it's minus 2 square root n
remember n is the dimension of the
matrix so this is the so-called bulk of
the spectrum and the edge is over here
so this is the spectral normal X so in
this case the spectral norm of X is of
order 2 square root n right if all the
entries are iid with the same width
variance 1 the edge of the spectrum is
at level 2 square root this has been
known for a very very long time ok since
the bulk has been known since the 50s by
Wigner and the edges have been known
since the early 80s
going to dance so now let's look at the
structure case so what are the bounds
that we can get in the structured case
so the most trivial bound structured so
the most trivial bound is just to mimic
Wiegand so what can we say ok all the
variances are different right but we
should if we increase all of the
variances which would only increase the
norm of the matrix so we can just upper
bound this matrix by a matrix whose
bigger matrix whose variance is just a
maximum of the variances of the end
so what bound would that give you well
it would give you a bound of the
expected norm of X is bounded by
something which I'll need in a moment so
I'm going to give it a name Sigma star
square root n where Sigma is just a
maximum
my maximum standard deviation a very
simple bound I just pretend okay I have
all of these entries they have different
parishes let's just take the worst one
now it behaves like a bigger matrix so
this bound is true it's useful it
actually has a exact constant 2 over
here I'm going to come back to these
bones so the other thing that's known
are the so called matrix concentration
equality is non commutative tension you
know these types of bounds have been
known since the 1980s and they're
extremely popular right now ok and if
you apply these bounds so let's call it
matrix concentration matrix
concentration bound in this case you get
the following bound so you can just
check it if you know these bounds so you
get a different parameter Sigma times
square root log in this parameter Sigma
is the maximum Euclidian norm of the
rows of this matrix so it's the maximum
over I of the square root of the sum
over J of bij squared so you see the
dimensional dependence here on n is much
better but the constant sitting in front
is much much larger because here you
have the Euclidean norm of a row and
here you just have the maximum variance
there is one more bound so I've now I'm
now exhausting the literature basically
there's one more bound due to Litella
which is very well known so the table
has the following bound the expected
norm of X is bounded above by the same
constant Sigma over here rather than x
you have plus
when you just put a single bar here for
so this just denotes the entry wise l4
norm of the entry so it's the sum of the
entries through the power 4 and then to
the power 1 force so I want to convince
you that none of these bounds do
anything get you get even close to
capturing the structure of this matrix
so let's take a simple example so first
of all what happens in the beginner case
so in the weaker case all of the BI J's
are equal to 1 we know the right answer
so in the beginner case of course the
Wigner bound is sharp by construction
right we've taken here the Wigner bound
right in this case Sigma star is equal
to 1 so the expected norm of X is over
the square root in sharp obviously but
in the vigener case if we look at the
matrix concentration bound okay all of
the entries are equal to 1 so Sigma is
square root n so the matrix
concentration bound would predict that
the expected norm of X is square root n
log n which is not correct right it's
much too big
what does dalits bound said well the
Talas bound a sharp for Vigna matrices
so this is square root n and this is
also square root n ok you can compute it
so the Talas bound for victor matrices
is okay right so for in in in in the
bigger matrix case make this
concentration gives the wrong answer but
the other two bounds give the right
answer now let's consider the other
extreme what's the other extreme let's
take a diagonal matrix which have
independent normal 0 1 entries on the
diagonal and 0 everywhere else so the
norm of this matrix is just the maximum
right it's the maximum of the absolute
values of the diagonal entries right so
this is the maximum of n iid Gaussian
random variables normal 0 1 so the
correct scale of the norm is square root
login right so let's see what these
bounds give so if in this case the
maximum variance is still 1 so the
beginner bound gives square root n which
is way off right it's much much larger
than square root log in matrix
concentration gives the right answer
because in this case in the diagonal
case Sigma is 1 so make this
concentration give you square root login
which is why you often see the claim
that matrix concentration is sharp this
is the example people give this is more
or less what people see is this is well
it's the only example in which is this
true ok at least in the independent set
right
and what does Lata us-bound tell us so
this one's now sharp what is the thumb
tell us well Sigma is now a word of one
but the L form everything entrances were
to end to the one-fourth so n to the
one-fourth is better than square root n
but it's still way more than square root
plugin you see i have two extreme cases
right and both of them have a disjoint
set of methods for which they give a
sharp result so somehow order none of
these methods are capturing the actual
structure right so we really would like
to understand at least in this sort of
simple case can we really understand
what aspect of the structure is is
captured by the X by the norm of the
matrix yes so okay if you believe that
then you should never ever use the
matrix concentration method okay which
is the standard method nowadays being
used in the theory of high dimensional
statistics all right in this area so you
know I'm not making judgments here right
I'm just saying look these methods are
not actually capturing the structure
they give you some upper bounds but none
of them are actually capturing the
correct structure of this matrix so let
me show you a result
here's our result so here's our bump so
there's two bounds there's an upper
bound in the lower bound what's always
true is that the expected norm of X
that's your equals Sigma plus Sigma star
square root log you see a lot of the
ingredients of shows up in this number
they show up in different places so here
you get Sigma times square root log in
it's way too big Sigma should just show
up additively you should still have a
square root log in otherwise you
couldn't capture the diagonal but it has
this much smaller constant setting we're
over
we have the following bound very nice
right under mild assumptions I'll
explain to you what the mild assumptions
are and what what you might hope to him
but even just the fact that we have an
upper and a lower bound it almost always
match means that this is really
capturing much better the structure it
is capturing in almost all cases the
structure of this matrix so now I'm
going to try to explain to you why
actually because this is a an audience
where maybe these these methods will be
used I just want to point out maybe I'll
just write down one more general result
just to convince you these things are
useful
many of these many of these many of
these assumptions are not needed what's
really crucial for these bounds is that
the entries are independent and of
course we would really like to have
these bounds for cases where the entries
are not independent okay we don't know
how to do that and that's a big open
problem but in the independent entry
case so so let me just write down one
result that has proved to be useful in
applications which is the following
let's say that the matrix X is n by N
and by M let's say so it's a rectangular
matrix and the entries X IJ are iid and
uniformly bounded I'll write it down in
a moment
not iid come on independent otherwise
it's not interesting independent
so now we can have a bound of the
following type the probability that the
spectral norm of X is greater or equal a
constant let's say 3 times Sigma plus T
is less or equal the minimum of n m and
e to the minus T squared over some
constant let's say 300 or something like
that
you can try to optimize it times Sigma
star well in this case Sigma squared is
the maximum over I sum over J of the
variances of the entries and Sigma star
is the maximum over I and J of the
uniform and norm of the inverse this
result applies to bounded random
variables but those of you who are
familiar of matrix concentration bounds
see immediately that this bound is much
much much sharper then you can ever
expect to get from matrix concentration
right because matrix concentration has
rather than Sigma star Sigma over here
and this is exactly what makes the
squared log n show up in the wrong place
when you get the bound on the
expectation these types of results are
very useful and and and can be used for
example to to get sharp bounds on the
phase transitions as the caste plot
models which emmanuel talked about and
my co-author has done that in this case
there's so much structure you might even
be able to use another method right but
in many cases there is not I want to
convince you what is the mechanism
that's going on here ok actually I can't
convince you because I don't really know
all right but let me try to prove the
lower bound ok then you see what I mean
by mild assumption then you see what
sort of phenomenon is going on so what
why should this be true so let's compute
this lower bound
actually we will do two lower bounds
we will first lower bounded by Sigma and
then we below abound it by something
like this so if it's lower bounded by
the maximum of the two it's also lower
bounded by the average of the two right
so this this is just up to a constant so
how do you know about this by Sigma well
this is very easy at least if you'll
give me one well-known fudge okay
because these are gaussian random
matrices the expected norm of x is of
the same order as the expected norm
square of a possible ideal one norm in
the l2 norm are of same order
do you have a question oh all right this
is a very standard result you can prove
that you can derive from the Gaussian
proper inequality okay so so Kinchin if
you want it doesn't matter all right so
let's if you take this for granted now
life is very easy you see I have your
expected norm of x squared Jensen's
inequality says that this is bounded
below by the norm of the expectation of
x squared this is less or equal than the
norm of the expectation of x squared I
just brought the expectation inside the
norm and you can compute this the
expectation of the x squared is just a
diagonal matrix which has these numbers
on the diagonal right so this is equal
to Sigma you see this lower bound by
Sigma is just measuring the lower bound
of the matrix on average if I average
the matrix and then I take the norm
right I get already Sigma right so the
Sigma is measuring how large the matrix
is on average on the other hand I can
take the expected norm of X and I can
lower lower bounded by adjust the
expectation of the maximum entry of X
yes yes why the expected real 5 minutes
or a fake 5 minutes vo 5 minutes so I
can blow a bound this by the expected
maximum entry of X it's not a trivial
lower bound but you see these are
independent Gaussian random variables
and the maximum of independent Gaussian
random variables tends to be a border
square root log n times their variance
at least if there
enough large ones so this is less or
equal Sigma star square root log n as
long as there are enough entries that
are almost as large as the largest entry
right so as long as this is what I mean
by the mild condition there are at least
some polynomial number of entries whose
standard deviation is of some of the
similar order to the maximum standard
deviation so it's not 2 to multiscale
right there you if you have extremely
multi scale matrix this bound may not be
sharp you can see it right because it's
dimension dependent if I took a matrix
which was all zeros except I'd have a
little corner but for another matrix in
it of course I shouldn't pick up the
full dimension of the matrix I should
just pick up the dimension in the corner
right so you cannot expect miracles
right or if a dimension dependent dot
yes yes you can replace this end by
something called the effective dimension
which is something like yield to norm of
the entries divided by the affronting
over the entries but this completely
does not capture structure so yes you
can do that for free and it does not
give anything interesting in almost any
example okay so it's an ad hoc
construction this is not the right
notion of dimension for this but I can
explain that but not right now
so actually one conjecture question is
is it true that you always have for
Gaussian matrices the expected norm of X
is of the same order as the sum of these
two quantities
because if this were true and it isn't
there's no counter example known in the
gaussian case this cannot be true for
any distribution must only be true in
the gaussian case okay there's no no
counter example known to this if this
were true this would completely explain
right so so what is bound is saying in
some sense at least under a model at the
assumption is that there only two
reasons why they expect an order matrix
can be large either the matrix is large
an average order is an entry which has a
large fluctuation right so if we could
prove this we would really be able to
solidify this unfortunately the upper
bound doesn't work this way the upper
bound works to a completely different
method actually the proof is very simple
and very nice it works from a form of
compression but not in the sense of
information theory so if anybody wants
to know how the proof force I'll be
happy to do it on the board in person
okay but yes by plying will give me by
pieces you gave examples where you know
one was fine and the other one wasn't
flirt you have an example matrix which
you know has these normals for
independent normals in there which I
can't split it into the sum of you know
two independent matrices and reason
about it some way
you asked me offline because I don't
understand the question okay I have a
preprint on my website that's not really
a preprint that's more of a working note
because I'm not pleased with the results
enough to submit it but I actually have
a preprint on my website where this
question is starting to be addressed and
we're using a completely different proof
than the proof of this result okay but
we're not there yet and but but we need
a completely new method and you can
actually show that the method we use to
prove this result could never give
something a short business but
nonetheless okay I'm going to wrap up
because I'm out of time almost two
minutes I think
but you see okay what would one want
there are many other questions okay so I
could write down here at least six other
questions each of them completely
different all right each of them equally
interesting of course one i'm not going
to bend that far from the applied point
of view of course you know in many cases
you might not want to have independent
entries you might want to have a more
general model of animate receipts which
is actually for example both the Wigner
bound then the matrix concentration
bound actually applies to a more general
class of random matrices the proofs that
we have are very much dependent on the
independence of the entries so of course
it's very natural to expect that there
is a generalization of this it works in
a much more general setting our proofs
don't okay and so this is very
interesting and you know we would like
to have this but but at the very least
the message you should take away from
this is that you know there very few
methods in the literature that can
capture structure and none of them
captured correctly at least in this case
right so at least in one case I've shown
you in a case that's actually useful we
have we have really understood somehow
the mechanism that makes these that
makes the structure of the matrix appear
and the expected mode right and I think
to me that's the interesting thing my my
co-author Rafael so he is you know he's
on the job markets right so so there's a
paper that's been six months in the
writing which hopefully will come out
soon he is writing a paper where he
applies this result to bound random
laplacian matrices it turns out this
gives you a sort of unifying principle
for proofing for example connectivity
transition in Irish Rainey and the
sharpness of SDP validations and things
like this so be on the lookout for this
paper if your interests in this type of
application result has also been used to
give minimax balance from a tree's
completion by olga club i'm
I saw it appear in the archives I don't
just pointing it out right so so already
these bands are getting useful results
right but um we would really like to
understand more structure and their many
open questions like this oh okay I rap